qu'est ce qu'un chat comment
définiriez-vous rigoureusement ce qu'est
un chat dans la série sur l'ia on avait
vu que en 2012
en un sens google était parvenu à enfin
fournir nos définition rigoureuse que ce
qui est un chat en concevant un
algorithme qui réagit si et seulement si
il est exposé à une image de chat de
nouveau pour les algorithmes à base de
réseaux de neurones arrive même avoir un
concept qui s'allument à la fois lorsque
l'algorithme est exposé à une image de
chats mais aussi quand il lit ou entend
le mot chat mieux encore ces algorithmes
peuvent effectuer des opérations
sémantique en manipulant le concept de
chat par exemple en transformant des
chermignon rocha hills terre et bien sûr
je parle des chats mais ça marche aussi
avec les chiens et tout ça à bien y
réfléchir c'est vraiment stupéfiant
certes ces algorithmes arrive à détecter
les chats et les chiens dans des images
à relier sa à des textes qui lisent et
même à manipuler ces concepts mais
est-ce qu'il comprenne vraiment de quoi
il s'agit après tout au fond ces
algorithmes ne font que manipuler des
beats c'est à dire une suite de 0 et de
1 dans des fichiers informatiques qui
représente ces images
alors que nous a priori nous voyons ces
images mais ces algorithmes les ouates
il ose aussi vu qu'au final ils n'ont
accès qu'une bande 2-0 2-1 quand ils
sont exposés à un fichier jpeg est ce
que les chats qu'ils pensent voir
correspondent vraiment à des vrais chats
peut-on vraiment dire qu'il ya de vrais
chats dans la suite des beats analysés
par des algorithmes de façon plus
vertigineuse encore on peut se rendre
compte que tout ce que les algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle ont vu et
auront vu au cours de leur apprentissage
n'est qu'une bande 2-0 et 2-1
dès lors peut-on vraiment dire que ce
qu'ils auront alors à prix correspond
vraiment à l'état du monde
prenons en particulier le cas plus
concrète de l'algorithme de youtube qui
analysent 500 heures de vidéos chaque
minute ainsi que l'historique de
visionnage de 2 milliards d'utilisateurs
et leurs commentaires
clairement cet algorithme ne fait qu
analyser des informations encodées dans
une bande 2-0 et 2-1
ce raisonnable de penser que cet
algorithme pourrait parvenir à
comprendre le monde à comprendre non
seulement l'existence des chars et leurs
interactions avec les humains mais aussi
peut-être le rôle de l'argent dans nos
sociétés du travail de la loyauté et les
impacts du changement climatique surtout
ceux ci lire des 0 et des 1 peut-il
vraiment suffire à comprendre le monde
voire à mieux le comprendre que nous
pourrait le faire des humains peut-on
vraiment un ferrer l'état du monde avec
une suite de bits pour mieux disséquer
ses questions il est utile de s'attarder
sur comment nous autres humains sommes
parvenus à la compréhension du monde que
nous avons à pourquoi nous pensons ce
que nous pensons et se trouve que pour
comprendre notre monde nous autres
humains avons aussi besoin de nous
informer
c'est à dire de collecter des données
sur notre monde et alors on pourrait se
dire que pour y arriver nous lisons des
articles et regardons des vidéos mais a
donné à réfléchir ne s'agit pas là des
données brutes auxquelles nous avons
accès
quand on lit un article en fait ce sont
surtout des nerfs dans nos rétines qui
s'activent ou non en fonction de la
luminosité à laquelle ils sont exposés
donc les données brutes auquel nous
accédons correspondent davantage à
désactivation ou non de neurones
autrement dit il s'agit finalement de
données binaires ou quasi binaire est en
fait très largement traduisible en
signaux binaire si l'on combine
l'ensemble des données collectées par
nos différents sens de l'image que l'on
voit à la chaleur que l'on ressent en
passant par l'odeur le son le goût le
sens de l'équilibré ou le toucher parmi
d'autres sens on se rend compte que
l'ensemble des données dont on dispose
n'est en fait pas si différent d'un
fichier binaire reçu à chaque instant en
fait si l'on admet la thèse de church
turine le théorème de shannon nuque
liste où la limite est de bekenstein et
semble que l'ensemble de nos données
sensorielles est en fait équivalent à
une suite de 0 et de 1 no sense data
comme le dirait bertrand russell toute
l'information sur le monde à laquelle
nous avons accès semble ainsi isomorphe
à un code binaire est alors oui pensez
ça c'est assez fou et vertigineux et
vous avez peut-être l'intuition que
quelque chose ne va pas dans ce
raisonnement que vous avez accès à
quelque chose de plus que les cents data
et peut-être que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir accès une
or nations non informatisent abl si
c'est ce que vous vous dites
rappelez vous que toute l'information
disponible sur internet en jeu vidéo ou
dans les salles de cinéma
tout ceci est de l'information
informatisé de façon très contre
intuitive avec une longue suite de 0 et
de 1
il est largement possible de décrire des
choses extrêmement complexe aussi
complexe que des films jeux vidéo et si
l'on en croit la limite de bekenstein
sans doute même aussi complexe que notre
univers tout entier
admettons donc que tout ce que nous
savons du monde ce soit effectivement
l'immense suite de 0 et de 1 que nos
sens collecte quelle serait alors la
longueur de ce code binaire
quelle est la taille des données à
laquelle nous avons et nous aurons eu
accès sans doute un truc immense non
après tout l'expérience humaine paraît
extrêmement complexe et bien on peut
faire les calculs et les chercher a
estimé la complexité de l'expérience de
vie d'un humain
d'après cet article en tout cas on
estime que nos yeux collecte environ 1
gigaoctet de données par seconde
cependant cette information est
automatiquement réduite de manière
inconsciente par le cortex visuel à
environ 1 kilo octets de données par
seconde
si on suppose que l'information reçue
par les autres sens après ce genre de
traitement inconscient est au plus de
l'ordre du ko par seconde ce qui semble
raisonnable vu à quel point on s'appuie
sur la vue force est d'admettre qu'à
chaque seconde
nous ne sommes probablement conscient
que de quelques kilo octets de données
or nous ne vivons que quelques milliards
dhs secondes seulement et je le sais
j'ai dépassé le milliard de seconde il
ya quelques mois
et oui je me fais vieux mais alors au
rythme de ko par seconde pendant
quelques milliards de seconde
on en vient à conclure que les données
sensorielles de nos vies qui agissent
sur les parties réflexive de nos
cerveaux semble en fait être de l'ordre
du tera octets et ça c'est à la fois
beaucoup et incroyablement peu à titre
de comparaison un bouquin comme le
fabuleux chantier fait autour d'un
mégaoctet
ainsi toute notre expérience de vie se
résumait à environ un million de
bouquins de cette épaisseur en
particulier de façon très troublante
toute son expérience de vie
pourrait être stockables sur un
ordinateur d'aujourd'hui comme quoi je
ne rends pas grand chose alors je suis
sûr vous avez quelques réserves par
rapport à cela mais je vous demande de
faire au moins l'expérience de pensée
imaginons que cela soit possible mettons
toutes les données sensorielles de l'est
dans un ordinateur et laissons
maintenant un bon algorithme
ils ont un algorithme quasiment
bayésiens laissons cet algorithme lire
ces données sensorielles cas prendrait
alors cet algorithme à quoi
ressemblerait les calculs d'un tel
algorithmes au début l'algorithme serait
certainement un peu perdu il y aurait du
mal à comprendre la logique du fichier
qui lie mais au final tout ceci ce n'est
peut-être pas si différent d'un bébé qui
découvre le monde dans lequel il vit
mais avec le temps comme les algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle exposés à
des vignettes youtube
l'algorithme qui lit mes données
sensorielles finirait son doute pas
remarqué des régularités dans ces
données
il faudrait peut-être par remarquer que
certaine régularité peuvent être
expliqués en invoquant un concept qui
lie ces régularités comme peut-être le
concept de chars le lecteur
algorithmique de mes données
sensorielles inventerait plus
globalement une façon d'interpréter les
données et parviendrait peut-être à
s'imaginer tout un monde animé par ces
données un peu comme lorsque vous lisez
une suite de caractères dans un livre
d'harry potter par exemple vous arriver
peut-être à vous imaginer tout un monde
animé par les caractères du livre le
lecteur algorithmique de mes données
sensorielles pourrait même finir par
imaginer que le fichier qui s'explique
mieux s'il imagine qu'il s'agit de
données sensorielles d'un individu il
pourrait même expliquer au mieux les
données sensorielles en imaginant qu'il
l'ait cet individu il pourrait ainsi
concevoir un modèle efficace pour
expliquer les données dont le postulat
de base avec le lecteur des données est
un être conscient qui vit l'expérience
de ressentir les données sensorielles
l'algorithme pourrait même adopté un
modèle où certaines de ces données
s'expliquent par le fait que l'être
conscient prend des décisions de la même
manière qu'en lisant un roman écrit à la
première personne un lecteur peut finir
par s'identifier avec le personnage et
même avoir l'impression de l'incarner et
de prendre les décisions que prend le
personnage le lecteur algorithmique
pour être ainsi être plongée si
profondément dans un roman qu'il
visualise tous les composants de ce
roman et en vient à les confondre avec
sa réalité les même s'il est quelque
part conscient de ne pas faire partie de
la réalité qu'il imagine en explorant
les données sensorielles de les
parcourir ces données pourraient être
une expérience plus immersive que la
plus immersive des expériences
sensorielles qu'on puisse imaginer avec
la réalité virtuelle ou avec d'autres
sortes de fiction alors je conçois
totalement qu'imaginer ceux qui
imagineraient un tel lecteur
algorithmique est extrêmement complexe
et peut-être que ce que je dis la dcri
très mal des calculs que ferait alors un
tel algorithmes néanmoins il ne semble
pas complètement improbable que
l'algorithme en question pourrait alors
effectuer des calculs qui d'une certaine
manière son traduisible en l'expérience
du personnage qui a vécu les données
sensorielles lui par l'algorithme en un
sens les calculs de l'algorithme
pourrait alors peut-être isomorphe à
l'expérience de vie de l'individu
ces calculs pourraient alors suggéré
l'existence de chats alors que
l'algorithme au fond ne ferait que lire
la suite de 0 et 2 hors
alors si vous raconte
vaincre que nous autres humains sommes
nous aussi des machines qui ne ferait
que lire un code binaire
même si il ya des réflexions assez
étourdissante avoir dans ce sens non si
je vous raconte tout ça c'est plus pour
insister sur le fait que au fond tout ce
que nous savons vraiment ce sont nos
données sensorielles
ce que l'on sait du monde ne
correspondent qu'à ce genre
d'informations brutes et tout ce que
nous imaginons ensuite du monde de
l'existence des chats à celui de la
choucroute c'est une reconstruction de
l'esprit un modèle que notre cerveau a
fabriqué à partir des données brutes est
certes il n'est pas impossible que ce
modèle soit effectivement relativement
conforme à une réalité extérieure
cependant il me semble utile de garder
en tête que ce modèle est un ferrer de
nos données sensorielles en particulier
son degré de validité est fortement
dépendant de la manière dont on est
passé des données sensorielles au modèle
en question ou dit autrement il dépend
fortement de l'épistémologie qu'on a
utilisée pour passer des données brutes
à des modèles qui explique bien ces
données brutes et à la limite tout cela
ne serait pas dérangeant si on avait de
très bonnes raisons de croire qu'on
utilise une bonne épistémologie
malheureusement si vous avez vu cette
série
j'espère vous avoir convaincus que ça
n'a rien d'évident mais alors il semble
absolument crucial de réfléchir beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus à l'épistémologie
n'utilise à l'épistémologie on devrait
utiliser
comment sait-on ce que l'on sait comment
passe-t-on de nos données brutes à des
théories sur l'univers comment les
données sensorielles modifient-elles nos
modèles du monde
le mathématicien léopold chroniqueur
aimait dire que dieu a créé les nombres
entiers et que le reste est une
fabrication de l'homme en sous-entendant
notamment que certaines fabrications à
la cantor n'ont pas de réalité
si dieu existe je dirais que cette
citation ne me semble pas tout à fait
adéquates
il semble plutôt que dieu a créé nos
données sensorielles et que les hommes
ont ensuite fabriqué un modèle de
l'univers à partir de ces données
sensorielles ou dit autrement
dieu a créé des bandes de bits le reste
est une fabrication humaine de petites
non ce avant de passer à vos
commentaires de la vidéo précédente on
vient de commencer un autre podcast avec
des amis de l'opl qui s'appelle robuste
et beneficial qui est un peu casse dans
lequel on parle de sécurité et d'éthique
des intelligences artificielles et en
particulier en fait on parle de la
recherche qui a lieu dans ce domaine
donc le podcast est cette fois en
anglais plutôt parce qu'ils cherchent à
avoir une audience plus académique et du
coup plus international et je veux qu'on
présente le podcast avec notamment al
mahdi el mhamdi mais également avec
louis faucons qui est également l'auteur
de l'application pays en europe et ça
m'amène à la deuxième annonce qui est
qu'à la fin de chaque épisode désormais
il y aura un lien dans la description de
la vidéo vers un cuisse va et vient pour
tester vos connaissances et votre
compréhension de la vidéo que vous
viendrez d'avoir regardé l'année enfin
on avait parlé du rôle de l'information
en physique et eyes à akira fait la
remarque qu il y a un coût énergétique
finalement au calcul et que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut prendre en
compte et on est fait aujourd'hui en
particulier en russie on regarde les
machines à calculer et dépensent
énormément d'énergie et alors on peut se
demander quel est le coût énergétique
minimum d'un calcul est ce qu'il existe
une telle quantité vient en un sens il
existe une quantité qui ressemble un peu
à ça chaque calcul irréversible
correspond à une dépense énergétique
alors pour être un peu plus voici le
coût énergétique d'un calcul dépend en
fait de la température ambiante est en
gros plus il fait chaud plus le coût
énergétique d'un calcul irréversible
sera élevé en fait les deux sont même
proportionnelle ce qui veut dire que
quand on fait des calculs à une dans une
température très proche du zéro absolu
en fait on a très peu de dépenses
énergétiques par calcul alors ça c'est
pour les calculs irréversible mais pour
les calculs de façon très générale il y
à un autre limite qui existe et qui est
un peu similaire à la limite de
bekenstein qui a été proposé par le
mathématicien annecy à rim prime herman
qu'on parle de limites de primes herman
la limite de bremermann c'est le nombre
de cas qu on peut faire par seconde avec
une quantité de matières tenait donc
c'est en bits par seconde par kilogramme
et cette limite de près normal nous dit
qu'on ne pourra pas faire plus que 18
150 beat d'opérations par seconde par
kilogramme et avec ça on peut faire des
calculs assez amusant par exemple de
regarder combien de calcul on peut faire
si on utile
toute la terre on atteint la limite de
la physique pour le calcul est bien avec
toute la terre on peut faire disputant
75 opérations par seconde et ça en fait
ça ne suffit pas à faire certains
certaines opérations d'aujourd'hui en
turquie avec les algorithmes aujourd'hui
par exemple si on déchiffrer des codes
et bien il ya souvent des codes qui sont
conçus tels que le nombre de calculs
nécessaires pour déchiffrer le code sera
de l'ordre de 10 science 80 aux
discussions 120 par exemple auquel cas
il faudra potentiellement beaucoup plus
des milliards et des milliards à 10
milliards d'années avec toute la terre
pour pouvoir résoudre ce problème de
cryptographie et plus généralement est
facile de concevoir des problèmes pour
lequel toute la matière de tout
l'univers pendant un google d'année ce
sera insuffisant pour résoudre le
problème mathématique en question alors
ces liens entre la physique et
l'information peuvent paraître assez
déroutant et thomas kahn ne demandent
justement en quel sens à ce qu'ils
auraient de l'information dans un trou
noir
alors le véritable sens de l'information
dans un trou noir à avoir avec
l'entropie et c'est la même chose que
lorsqu'on parle de l'entropie d'un gaz
par exemple l'état en ce moment de
l'aide et toutes les particules
qui sont dans cette pièce là où je suis
ben pour pouvoir décrire ça précisément
il faudrait que je décrive les positions
et les villes vélocité de toutes les
particules
autour de moi il y en a sont un peu
prédictions de 26 dispense 27 et du coup
la description fine du gaz à l'intérieur
de cette pièce requiert énormément à des
millions 2 et a opté pour pouvoir être
décrits or souvent à notre échelle
lorsqu'on fait de la thermodynamique
on va juste se contenter de donner la
pression et la température du gaz et du
coup ce qui nous manque comme
information pour connaître l'état
physique de du gaz dans cette pièce à
partir uniquement dans une description
macroscopique et c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'entropie de la pièce et ça peut se
mesurer avec des unités de la physique
mais ça peut aussi se mesurer en vite ce
qui est plus naturelle et la même chose
a lieu pour un trou noir en particulier
pouvoir raconter comment est-ce que le
trou noir et enée quels sont les
particules et comment elle était son
arrivée sur le tournoi avant de passer
l'horizon des allocs des événements tout
se calcule la cc de l'information à
laquelle on n'a plus accès à une fois
que la matière a est passé dans le
tournoi ou au fur à mesure que le
tournoi a grossi et les englober et donc
c'est de l'information qui est perdu est
cette information on peut la mesurer
parce que j'ai mesuré l'information dans
un gaz et ça correspond en gros au fossé
entre l'histoire du tournoi et la
description macroscopique qu'on en fait
une fine et qui consiste à dire que le
tournoi à quelle masse par exemple alors
souvent en thermodynamique notamment on
va considérer que l'information qui est
perdue comme ça elle est perdue et les
cerneaux nière irrécupérable ça ça veut
dire que on ne peut pas concevoir en
gros deux machines qui va récupérer
cette information de l'état physique
mais on peut imaginer des structures
dans lequel il est possible d'avoir
c'est tros transcription de
l'information et finalement c'est
exactement ce qui se passe dans un
disque dur dans un disque dur l'une des
propriétés important du disque dur c'est
qu'il est capable n'est capable de lire
ce qui l'attend disque dur c'est à dire
de transformer cette information un
autre objet qui récupère en gros cette
information donc dans le cas d'un trou
noir
très compliqué de faire ça mais la
limite avec une fiche times ne dit que
il est possible en tout cas en principe
de mettre énormément d'informations dans
un mètre vingt mètres cubes en voit tous
une surface me pour un volume avec une
surface de 1 mètre carré est capable de
mettre à l'intérieur de cette surface en
gros 10 puissance 69 bits d'information
et ça serait comme un disque dur en ce
sens où il pourrait peut-être y avoir un
mécanisme encore au principe qui permet
de récupérer cette information et de la
copier coller ou d'accéder à telle ou
telle partie de l'information pour
mettre ensuite serra dans un téléphone
autres donc ça serait possible d'avoir
une autre machine qui récupère cette
information et en ce sens il y aurait
vraiment un stockage de 18 ans soit 9 69
pitt d'information à condition bien sûr
que c'est de l'information macroscopique
fait partie que ce ne soit pas de
l'information qu'ils soient perdus d'un
point de vue de thermodynamique
j'espère qu'ils avaient dans cette vidéo
et que vous voyez le lien avec pays la
prochaine fois on va un peu appliqué
tout ça à une question souvent discutée
à savoir l'existence du hasard notre
univers
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à la
likouala commentaire partagez vous
abonner l'épisode 9 6 aux tirs au but et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois au niveau du toucher vous êtes
capable de toucher
si vous faites bien attention vous
sentez sur chaque centimètre carré de
votre peau vous sentez le poids de vos
fringues mais on n'y fait jamais
attention parce qu'en fait si on faisait
attention en permanence à tout ce que
nos sens perçoivent on serait en mode
complet qui est ma commune chez une
formation
en fait la seule certitude à laquelle
l'expérience qu'ont surtout donne accès
c'est qu'il y a de l'expérience
consciente ce que nous menons ici des
perceptions une suite de perception dont
il n'est pas clair qu'il y est un mois
derrière la certitude absolue n'est pas
que moi je suis moi j'existe comme le
soutien des cartes et ghossoub ego
existe au mais simplement il y à des
perceptions russell dont je parle dans
un autre épisode aurait parlé de seize
dates à la certitude primitif
s'équilibre à 10 cents dates à un flux
constamment changeant de données
d'expérience
voilà